yeah okay laws can mean only one thing
Troy started clamping first welcome back
there really is humiliating when you see
like the audience deployment then you
see someone from the team likes to human
applause sign yeah so embarrassed we're
a tie we're in Montreal and Just for
Laughs comedy festival yes an hour left
yes I guess another thing he was
offended here to wash his giant balls
that's probably what it is that's right
[ __ ] onion teabag but we have a
auntie Letterman Dan Soder emotion
kasher and Natasha Leggero
hi and all of you beautiful people and
Natasha what shows you you are now you
all you have a lot more projects than
probably all of us no I want I have a
show are you doing exactly right she's
adjusting comfortably yeah you're right
I have a show on Comedy Central called
another period that is coming back I
think you guys get it on much but from
your applause maybe not call another
period and then also I'm playing Andrew
Dice clays life in dice just what I've
always pictured my wife would be doing
whatever you dice clay [ __ ] ha ha ha I'm
like not like revenant he's like oh I
got your wife oh that memo [ __ ] feel
like I want to [ __ ] did she go you
have to say the magic words you go
hickory dickory dock we put our arm all
the way around a section
guys because I find the Canadians are
like kind of sweet and easily offended
like I can't imagine them really in
Montreal Dane sweet no I'll do you guys
I would die for my popular peer at one
point because he's such a he's so anti
with a lot of the folks up here are he's
uh but he says in the offside toy with
him for a long time he's one of the
greatest guys and people who don't know
who had this weird impression of him
many a meet him he's like he's it's a
goofball he likes to he likes to be
babied and mother and he's like a sweet
guy shoplift yeah I would love to be
babying he's all he loved he he had like
a crew that follows him around that
consists of his current wife her mother
his ex-fiancee and they all give him
massages yeah but like different like
you know like the the wife's mom knows
how to work the area the speed and then
the other the ex-wife stop steps on his
back like he's got a whole system worked
out but I worked with him it was I would
be opener club so to Kenny and happy
face if he met happy face and sloppily
no no no he's a martial artist days they
were bodyguards for Andrew and he would
get the massage and what he would do it
he would lay in bed he let a man massage
him cuz he told he would ask me to
massage him I'm like I'm not gonna
[ __ ] miss ya he would get men to
massage him but he would do his happy
face they would do you know put the
pillows on happy Andrew would lie in his
bed in Vegas happy put the [ __ ] the
pillow over dices ass so there was no
man to man contacted he would straddle
him and dig into laughs oh yeah was
breaking news Andrew Dice Clay is a
massage freakiest body work no he is a
he is and never met anyone like him I
mean he's he's kind of a maniac yes he
was he we were in a Rite Aid and he was
like stealing candy and then he's like
it tastes better when it's free that's
exactly the opposite of how I feel about
section
but yeah he's all he was we she went on
a Harley Davidson store in Vegas and
Andrew would would just put sweatshirt I
could I've never seen anybody steal like
him so he's a klepto oh boy and then
Emma Neal's make those two things I like
shoplifting and baby you don't smell
them stealing a massage nothing it's
difficult to go that's sort of
logistical concern really you gotta have
an understanding you to pay after the
massage then you walk out I mean he'll
smoke in the airport he'll smoke he's
like and people come up to him be like
sir you can't smoke in here he's like a
lot of beauty son like he just and then
I saw him put it cigarette out on this
palm like he's very thing do you know
what he used to say and we would tour
Kenny told me this would happen where
dice would smoke in the airport and
people would come up I saw him like
light up at baggage claim and people
with what people would come up to him
and go you can't smoke here who's going
on as we got a special permission from
the governor and he was so canal you
probably couldn't do it that lately real
when the whole non-smoking he was just
kicking in he would say that and wish it
on the governor and he would offer nerve
he's a great actor so he's so deadpan
with it like all right I love the idea
of that in reality of a real governor
like Andrew died - yes definitely
expensive this mistaken you say Benson &
Hedges at the airport indeed yes he is
he is a very accidentally funny and
intentionally funny bird yeah so but
he's so different than people would
expect when you when you meet him like
people expect to be a certain way and
you're great on the show you're so good
I'm sure yeah I'm sure it's really
really good it is I'm happy for him
Justin - starts August 20th amazing so
we you guys have we guys doing up here
we're comedians were at the justa
laughing in Sam's defense with these two
couches that looks like a rich couples
visiting their white trash
hahaha like 80 and I like y'all ready
here a spa it rolled up in our bang bus
oh yeah it's a TIG welding that's how
yeah I'm a screenwriter
we love your glasses oh yeah your reason
which'll looks rich with his socks and a
slide huh mm-hmm
very like I really dress up very well
I know it's like I'm so rich it doesn't
even matter what's on my feet
well actually I'm incredibly
fashion-forward and looked great yeah I
just want to clarify that for the
listeners at home and I are on tour and
we just like we're on this honeymoon
tour can you guys shut up
yeah in the back yeah we're very loud
back there that's the only break the
maids get in there all right I guess we
won't have our time idea that I had that
must be the [ __ ] worse to work at
this hotel and a bunch of clowns staying
here
we're like my jokes are important my
guests are important
you think this is the worst job of their
year this is worse than the like
international plastic manufacture
attraction for just 32 Soleil all the
body paint left on boys I'm sorry Safari
the people who dress up and [ __ ] in
animal costumes
well they kind of SAP up their own come
with the it is a wet dog show yeah
actually why they do the furry thing
it's not about the first we don't need
morally free anyway Moshe and I are on
tour where we have a honeymoon tour so
we're entering the second year of what
I'm trying to do is a ten year honeymoon
and we are we have like five cities left
yeah we're going to Boston Chicago New
York Philadelphia and Minneapolis those
are our remaining dates
Natasha good plug subtle I like that way
okay I knew a headlining set motion as a
headlining set if he can follow that Oh
[Applause]
who she married to you would die and
then we do live relationship counseling
which has been the most fun part of you
to her I think the last time I saw
Natasha at Caroline's it got really
really weird because there was like a
couple fighting or something in the
crowd in the crowd you to bring them up
on stage was that it I remember we was I
would didn't Caroline's with Natasha
once and she did this joke about getting
an AIDS test at the DMV agree yeah I
opened with it and this woman it's a
great job this one I don't remember what
it is anyway they're doing the HS at the
DMV now oh right the only thing worse
than standing line at the DMV is finding
out you have AIDS for some reason I
decided to open with that joke at
Caroline's this woman gets up with her
she's like my brother has AIDS she
thought she was like my license is
expired
I found that whole process very
convenient got up and her entire table
all left and that was like I still had
48 minutes left
Oh awesome good get them out early
absolutely there are people out oh your
brother's a food get out of my show
anybody have not enough friend with age
come on up sitting this way boys are
going to be my honor is where what sends
people out of the room like you know
it's [ __ ] 2017 you can't make it yeah
I like I liked when I was working with
you years ago and make one of us in
Jersey ones and like a couple it was a
nice unassuming couple that wandered
into a comedy show having no clue what
they were going to see and they stood up
pretty early and you were really nice
about you're like I can't be for
everyone they obviously didn't know what
they're coming into and I like that I
think about that every time the full
audience leaves when I'm performing is
they not really for anyone or by the way
a Jim Norton ticket is not like a
two-for-one at the local chuckle joint
it's like they spent money to get there
they didn't do a cursory are you on the
show you don't have to like pan you
don't feel like bags
I'm not pandering I'm saying things are
overpriced and they pay for the room in
they're overpriced having a Google ight
Google server what am I going to watch
this you okay not for me with it like
just dirty jokes or like sex stuff you
know you never know it depends on when
people a lot of comedy clubs I've never
happened in the theater but in a comedy
club a lot of times they're just they
just go to the comedy club and once in a
while if they're quiet and they leave I
don't say anything I was at the the
Melrose improv recently I was doing
something and I was having a great set
and this [ __ ] couple up front these
[ __ ] people I could see them like
almost texting across hated my [ __ ]
gut and I finally said something
normally if they're not making noise
it's not my business if they laugh but
they were being such [ __ ] and people
could notice them hating and so they
finally left but I think they were at
the wrong show not even I think you
asked them like well you ready were
there I was there and you were they it
was the most peaceful walkout I've ever
seen because you got you were like
confronting them near like you guys
haven't left you I don't think you're
enjoying this blah blah blah and after
like three questions you were like whoa
are you in the wrong room got it done
they were like yeah yeah yeah that's we
were texting about we we came to the
wrong club and they they laugh and they
were in the wrong room we're just going
for sushi yeah I don't even know this
man you're talking about incest I just
want to have a California roll want to
see the bringer show in the lab we
didn't want to see your professional
comedy well you know what it is - it's a
guy and you know of course I'm like well
you know all right well thanks for
coming but I'm really hoping like how
great would it be if a drunk driver
plowed into the moment way out like oh
we should have just listened to him more
we don't want to this day all right I
hate people who walk out I mean I try to
be nice now but I [ __ ] hate him I had
a one that completely derailed me at the
cellar right when I got in I was doing
it was like I was in the middle of my
act and this woman just got up and she
goes I heard this last week oh my it
just starts to walk out and I go yeah
what an SP you'd walk into the room and
it's like one of those things rose like
double terrified they go
I'm a comedian that's what we do and
she's like now I'm sure those [ __ ]
cigarette you just do your thing like
that
oh my god oh just you know it's okay
just dude she was like trying to be mean
but you yes she was okay I have an idea
reviews of a person that thinks that a
comedy show ought to be catered to what
they saw one week earlier yes so [ __ ]
unbelievable yeah no it's people just
like I'm personally offended you were
supposed to know my uncle [ __ ] me with
the pickle why does your pickle joke
it's like shut up
we didn't have a survey beforehand I
don't want to what a creative uncle
absolutely absolutely sit down he works
with what he has and they also you eat
the evidence
I only [ __ ] with Bill I know and he
talked like that IRA short story where
he [ __ ] his niece with the pickle and
he feeds it to the cops afterward that's
a deep cut for you guys I had a woman
stand up and call me racist like and I
had not mentioned race it was it was a
woman a table black woman who were
talking and I just like addressed it and
she went you're racist and I was like I
mean I'm not do you it was like we need
a fork like can we get some before click
I'm trying to help them stop talking and
then she goes she goes just do your job
and I'm like I'm trying to do my job
you're all talking shut the [ __ ] up and
then she ends up like getting up she's
like you need to retire and I was like
that is so nice of you to think that I
would have like a full career and then
retire and maybe like Florida I love the
idea that at the moment you said I am
NOT a racist
a black man sat directly next to you Joe
I'm gonna fact-check this story he's
into his eyes am i known the recent
right say Ferrante that's well wrong
here tie everybody it seems like I was
needed anytime a white girl says I'm not
racist Ron Funches appears he's like
beetle - I didn't say I wasn't racist I
said I hadn't said anything racist joke
yeah I just go oh is that true or they
let me have sex with
that really is the acid test of racism
where you [ __ ] off boxes I'm up there
doing the Lord's work
why not kids I am NOT raising GBP
welcome to the show that you doing your
own thing up here already are you what
are you doing the festival
yeah I'm doing some our show or four
years little shows and then just run
around doing random [ __ ] what a whiner
can people see you they could see me at
a place whose name I often forget I'm
not racist theater it's called bring
your white [ __ ] yeah please
great name for a tour that is a good
thing it's called monument national
something like that it's at 10:30 at
night I'm doing some fun material come
to it or not I'm doing well I'm
confident okay good for you
I'm just the opposite I'm begging for
people to come to the Gesu theater and
I'm [ __ ] Scatman Crothers hang it up
hope you do you say the important thing
is how did you feel - because I've
midnight God cancelled yeah and you were
I had vamp Ian I had a good ride on that
but you had a [ __ ] off phenomenal
we're happy to do 25 straight wins sure
20 wins 20 way and that doesn't matter
because it was a give not really like
WWE but that was fun it was a fun show
to do
yeah it's really fun I was just in the
stands that came out and give you a
chance to show your humor without
running through your material right and
that's the I mean as the big bone for
minx I don't like to write new material
I don't have to yeah and so it is just
kind of sad that it's ending especially
so suddenly
kind of wish they would you know give
you new host and Ron you should host it
yeah I don't really want to okay just
watch that full process yeah
Oh agents had to get involved no lawyers
great there were but they were just at
the other side of the door like shy run
in now
we'll be fine I'm sure I would no one no
one came to me with that option yeah I
feel like they should have had guest
hosts for a while I would have done a
wee yeah I would have done a week you
know could a gym could have done a week
right I would have done a week Natasha
yeah maybe they want to just put
somebody else there who know I don't
know I feel like an easy show to do as
long as you just have a hologram hosted
yeah and then the Canadians could all do
their thing that does sound
disrespectful you know a lot of those
people will be good at hosting you that
you can't be in two places at once
I can't be there we got the job Annie
you're on the road now full-time and
you're not doing that you any projects
you're working on her no I'm going to do
a few episodes ones ABC show called the
Goldbergs and oh yeah what is that back
heard of that show I have visions just
approaches what is it what is that
leering at me yeah it's like the Wonder
Years four legs and nine days and then
slowly oh it's about a family that I got
it took place in the 70s
I really haven't looked good I think
it's a yeah yeah I think you're right
you didn't read the script run Oh Robert
does the president support although I
was a crime girl well I'm pretty damn a
nice well it's about a Jewish family so
in a tangential way it's about an
insurance crime drama that's the [ __ ]
you guys man I know they got very tough
all of a sudden you should have said
midnight with that joke you okay Annie
but nobody even offered you the [ __ ]
job well if I was married to an agent
maybe I like you guys look like a couple
that's coming to or from Palm Springs
I'm getting roasted by the riffraff on
this counselor you guys look a couple of
rich people well we did just arrived
from Key West that is true we were at
keyword calling what I see I'm not hey
yeah all the couch looks like we all
just woke up here on this couch yeah
like I mean I like the way I did that's
why I do guys would like to set up for
every great joke I've ever told her I
like white guy black guy and a woman
fall out of a plane
[Laughter]
have you ever been married right or no
yeah it was married for how old a young
I was marry a CEO with my well first
wife first girlfriend Moshe actually was
a part of the story for us we still the
story is good and then at my 20s I got
divorced I don't remember because it was
a blur but I remember him when I was at
the lowest of this thing and really
depressed and really want to get out of
it and as at the Denver Airport just
really moping around to myself and I
just walked past this restaurant and I
see motion at this restaurant and he's
like you look like you're [ __ ] hate
life and so we sit down for like 10
minutes and I'm just talking about how
many new mine with my axe and he knew my
son and stuff and he was just like mom
and so you could still be a good dad and
you don't have to be married you can you
sound like you're not having fun and it
was really good conversation and it
really helped me get rid of that [ __ ]
but that was that that was a special
special afternoon of comics on the road
it was very weird because we were like
literally passing in an airport
terminals like Ron Moshe and we had like
an actual emotional connection but the
funnier part was that your wife one of
the things that she I don't know if I do
one of the things that she accused him
of in there in the in the [ __ ]
accusations was having an affair with me
do
I know you've been meeting with that
Moshe kasher guy over airplane yes you
were sucking his dick at Stapleton
International good call Jimmy Stapleton
yeah yeah yeah don't burn I remember the
shining yeah locations quiet an affair
with Moshe what made her think that it
was just probably the Sox with the Jim I
have no idea Lord I can feel the sexual
place so what what were you guys really
closed you spent a lot of time on the
road together I think she was probably
just grasping or son yeah yeah it was me
mostly it was like she was [ __ ]
around and a lot of people when you do
that you start queuing up she was having
an affair with who Natasha
yeah we would still be together
how'd you catch her how did you find out
I mean was never really like caught it
was more like I had to just put a lot of
info together she never really came out
came and said it that which is our like
harshest part is me like I know like I
know you did you like nah no we did some
things you see a text message that you
should know some Facebook stuff holy
moly just a shitty relationship overall
and we're hearing you're young yeah I
mean I she was my first girlfriend high
school did you cheat on her head yeah
you did yeah Moshe
we already well that's funny that she's
like not only do I think you're cheater
but I think you're gay yeah is I think I
can last grasp of most of people women
on the way out of a relationship with a
man it's like maybe with you Moshe I
mean that's crazy
well I've never been like you're gay
I've said that in the mirror
nice name
no no no one thinks I'm gay ever after I
put the stick on the one time but I did
but I know I mean I've heard many
stories of guys in relationships of
women who like it gets more and more
toxic and that their last move is like
maybe you're [ __ ] your friend like a
crazy
it's like bomb the village kind of like
maybe I can find something here yeah
oh geez no you think it's like usually
like an aggressive thing that they're
saying that to kind of burn you on the
way out
yeah maybe they maybe they've gotten to
the end of their excuses for why the
relationship isn't working and they're
like oh maybe this dudes again like
you're always going to hang out with the
guys what are you guys joking off on a
cookie like what is that yeah I mean you
point out the guy like carved a menu I
love the decks how innocent you go game
oh I did go ready to do a 12 year old
game I didn't want a young boys game no
means will they ask about the boys I
would knit knit and I had to go to the
bathroom I was my turn well anyone laced
with the cookie like that
what do you mean wasted you don't throw
it out silly you know dump them what a
cookie rookie yet anyone here ever
played a iteration of come on I think
it's a legend right who's Chang comas
talks a lot of [ __ ] to me because I said
that it's never happened never I'm
asleep over he's like it happens it over
sleepover sleepover you're going to vote
thing you see Louis with a cookie mask
and you're like all I get it my nickname
was a cookie mozzarella Tina
good girl that is a weird thing to
picture a bunch of guys jerking off over
a cookie little a skull has to eat it
it's also incredibly accurate with your
comb yeah yeah that's the part you got
to try to move it towards someone you
like yeah who's your best friend you try
to support it get closer I already got a
Cake Boss this how do you throw that
name oh is it like considered normal for
two guys to jerk off together I hope no
right no for two straight friends to
jerk off together yeah I would say that
I have done when I was a teen I did that
I would like to rock off in a room with
my teen friends there be no what do you
mean oh that is so good what if I was
reviewing a part of myself to you I mean
I guess I think you added Jean friend's
name is Ron Funches and what will you
actually watch it will you watch your
movie or are you just looking at each
other figure first one of points King
you're the cookie you're the cookie tell
this story no it's not much of a story
I've just you know when you're young
you're so to your sexuality so confused
when you look at them or would you guys
be like looking up I would look at their
back because I was inside of them anyway
I did have like a older gay friend that
would always like dog why don't we throw
a porno on and I'll sit around a
jerk-off we were so young dog okay cool
come on in now I told her in retrospect
it's like oh Europe you are a creepy
predator yeah how much older he was
probably 10 years older than oh my god
bad flour for Jimmy we were like
probably 16 or 15 and he was probably 26
Oh class it's not a bad story you guys
because
lasted no emotion who's not moshe was a
budding flower i wish people could see
your face then what happens one of you
that you don't all come at the same time
so that's how it works it's not around
you know it's like no it's like women's
periods we all think that yeah so what
would happen yeah that does that's a
great question because if you get no one
gate one of you comes there like you
immediately get up and go to your first
guy that comes is like what the [ __ ]
going on I'm going home yes queer o6e
you were gross
I like Natasha just staring at Moshe is
aside emotional face when this is going
on thinking like maybe this honey mode
tour is not going to get to ten years I
mean this is new information
well I mean it's not that big of a deal
it was before the internet so porn was
like yeah just outsource it like okay
you're good friends you're gay like
someone had a pour and you're like yeah
you got some [ __ ] currency absolutely
could you've heard all the stories about
the Cowboys in the Old West just jerking
off together horses inside horses what
is inside horse yeah I get touched
pretty normal I just whatever I mean not
that how many think it's weird that I
remember when I was like when I was like
not twelve or thirteen someone at the
black box that unscrambled cable oh yeah
and we were at my friend's house who had
it and they put on the spice channel one
of my friends was like oh what do you
have a boner and you're like it's
actually pretty healthy yeah
no sooner shame yeah use voter shaming
and did you have one yo for Kia and
what'd you do with it what'd you do with
that young turgid gift Alice I didn't I
was trying to sit I was my sitting
cross-legged I remember putting my pants
like a tent and I just like trying to
roll up Rollie pollie until it went away
like one of those insects that when you
pester it
hopefully I don't have a boner I can get
up now I was like gross already have a
boner at this naked woman getting [ __ ]
God we found this porno of my dad's that
he had made like oh you really set it up
like I was right
you're a circus tent what my parents did
make her jape at some point which my dad
just told me you know um can I at the
footage yeah that is a smash it with a
hammer they were like it was like just
two fat people [ __ ] so then we just
took it outside and smashed up why so
dramatic when I throw it out I don't
know it's just yeah we started it like
that REO at the end of Apocalypse Now no
need to be ritualistic we would we don't
know how fast they were they need it e
time they've since died and thank God
when I watch them [ __ ] now it's totally
awesome but um for my dad like all night
the day they died you're in the air in
the trash getting the real of mommy
daddy I'm missing with my father
[Music]
I have it in the background what
happened they told you bad but so there
was a porn my dad had made with like you
know when you would use like a camcorder
and a VCR so he like dub together all
these porn so we got to learn about porn
like through our dads you made it on a
Mickle and yeah wait yeah wait you're
telling me he did running commentary on
a porn master a director of science
either head but he like mr. senator he
did um uh Danny I want you to know if
you watch this I love you so very much
you're an apple of my eye now let's
watch this girl get TT yeah but it was
like it was all these it was kind of
like funny porn so it was like that
maybe they're not in a girl it's like
what is this like her your what kind of
party was born it just was like it was
like more like there was one where it
was like a girl in a limo and she was
they were like all right now give me a
[ __ ] then she started blowing on his
dick he's like that's not how you do it
and then they like taught her how to
give a blow job thanks daddy
oh wow that mistake I bet he didn't
think that video was gonna come back to
haunt him well that sounds like a great
porn someone who doesn't have to suck
dick again yeah I know now that I'm
saying this fun boner right now I always
do and I sit next to Sam right II want
so many times
give my boy your balloon for it so I go
so we find this point it's called
excerpts and my dad's handwriting sticky
little fingerprints all over and we like
I think we were like 11 I have a twin
brother an older brother and we would
like invite all of our friends I really
push the couch above the door and we'd
all watch it together like no one was
jerking off or anything but it was like
a family event and my dad sat us down
ones at like family dinners like
afterwards he was like we need to talk
to the family I want all the x-rated
videos returned to me because everyone
would just like we put them like in
different sleeves of different movies so
you didn't go to watch Jerry Maguire and
like a better set video without sure
so is that and they've gotten to play at
the bat at the end of the play boy the
better sex videos we're watching like
old people with short hair like
technically absolutely we want to see
Edgar Winter get laid I don't know guy
long hair
I hate myself for giving you a fake
laugh could have said Willie Nelson
alright we have two minutes left with to
wrap up Travis is holding up a sign I
remember when there was I didn't mean
ended so abruptly I want people to get
their plugs out of here it would float
with look not about I need two minutes
or plugs all I know I just say we should
wrap it up not end immediately so
there's wind down guys remember motion
when you're minute 48 start to wind down
as you go k so is the Iran public was
first founded in oh I know I remember
when I back in the day before the
internet why would I would get I would
rent porns because there were video so
the rent for me but we were so poor we
couldn't afford a new VCR we had lost
the remote so I would jerk off with a
broom and house your ass I would press
the broom on the fast-forward and a good
season
we should have done it with a mop so you
could have cleaned up
[Applause]